[Música]
y
cómo
en este planeta en el que vivimos existe
un ser vivo que supera y domina al resto
existen miles de millones de individuos
y con su actividad sin duda afectan de
manera dramática las vidas de todos los
animales y todos los seres vivos que
poblamos este planeta hablo sin duda de
las bacterias
están por toda la tierra están en la
antártida están en las profundidades
marinas están en el bosque está en este
teatro están en tu piel y está en tu
intestino está en el intestino de todos
incluso en el intestino de los
astronautas hay centenas y centenas de
diferentes especies de bacterias y todas
ellas viven en una perfecta armonía con
el ambiente que colonizan
algunas veces eventualmente las
bacterias se lanzan a colonizar un medio
nuevo un nuevo hábitat
y de ello el hombre consigue generar un
beneficio algunas veces
porque otras veces le causa un tremendo
daño estoy hablando de las infecciones
las infecciones ocurren cuando una
bacteria coloniza a nuestro cuerpo la
tuberculosis por ejemplo tuberculosis la
causa la bacteria mycobacterium
tuberculosis cuando colonizó nuestros
pulmones
la bacteria crece y obtiene la comida
que necesita para crecer de nuestras
células y destrozan nuestros pulmones
veis si os dais cuenta la bacteria no es
un ser maligno lo único que quiere es
crecer es sobrevivir el conflicto el
problema reside en que nosotros somos la
comida las bacterias han causado la
muerte de millones y millones de
personas a lo largo de la historia de la
humanidad y no hace falta a retrotraerse
a
la peste negra o la lepra a estas
pandemias que causaron estragos en el
medievo en europa bastaba solamente
pensar en que en los años 20 o en los
años 30 contraer una infección de
tuberculosis era prácticamente una
sentencia de muerte y la única
posibilidad que existía para paliar esa
infección era aislar a los infectados en
sanatorios en la sierra donde por un
lado se podía proteger a los no
infectados de las ciudades y a la vez
que se les proporcionaba a los
infectados sol aire fresco reposo para
que estuviesen fuertes y pudiesen
combatir la infección
yo nací en un pueblo de murcia que se
llama lama está el cito pequeño que está
a las faldas de sierra espuña en esa
sierra está este sanatorio de
tuberculosos afortunadamente ese
sanatorio está abandonado y amenaza
ruina pero hubo tiempo en que un punto
muy activo para recluir a enfermos de
tuberculosis intentar conseguir que se
recuperará con muy poco éxito muy pocos
conseguían recuperarse de esta infección
hoy hoy podemos abrir una ventana en el
tiempo podemos estar allí durante un
instante porque alguien tomó esta
fotografía cuando el sanatorio estaba
activo claro qué cantidad de gente y
cuánta gente joven estaba sentada en la
terraza tomando el sol esperando
recuperarse de la tuberculosis ajenos o
quizás resignados a un más que posible
fatal desenlace porque como ya he dicho
antes contraer una infección de
tuberculosis en aquellos tiempos era
prácticamente una sentencia de muerte
estos sanatorios al igual que otros
muchos cerraron fue parte de uso en los
años 50 los antibióticos los borraron
del mapa en lo que fue uno de los
descubrimientos más importantes de la
historia de la humanidad los
antibióticos son moléculas que producen
las bacterias para matar a otras
bacterias que compiten por colonizar el
mismo nicho
pero el ser humano gracias a su ingenio
ha conseguido extraer las y purificar
las y utilizarlas para su propio
beneficio para curar infecciones
los antibióticos han supuesto la
revolución de la medicina moderna del
siglo 20 porque gracias a ellos hemos
conseguido ejecutar procesos quirúrgicos
extremadamente complejos sin el peligro
de contraer infecciones durante el
proceso quirúrgico o post operatorias y
aparte de eso han ayudado sensiblemente
a erradicar las pandemias de la
humanidad el tifus el cólera
la lepra tuberculosis la gonorrea
sin embargo a día de hoy se puede decir
que los antibióticos han sido víctimas
de su propio éxito
porque los hemos usado de manera
incorrecta e inadecuada hemos abusado de
ellos
nos hemos incluido en todas las facetas
de nuestra vida
los hemos utilizado no solamente para
curar infecciones sino para prevenir la
posibilidad de contraer infecciones
hemos generado pasta de dientes con
antibiótico crema para el acné con
antibiótico pastillas para la tos con
antibiótico antibiótico en la comida
antibiótico en el agua
práctica de los ríos en las granjas en
los animales han tenido en todas partes
para protegernos porque funcionaba muy
bien
pero la vida siempre encuentra el camino
y las bacterias se adaptan porque
quieren sobrevivir como cualquier otro
ser vivo y evolucionan se convierten en
resistentes a los antibióticos
se llaman bacterias resistentes o super
bacterias y son capaces de crecer en los
medios que nosotros les envenenamos
intencionalmente con antibióticos y son
la razón de que en estas últimas décadas
haya habido un repunte muy significativo
en el número de infecciones proponer un
ejemplo cercano en españa mueren 30
veces más personas por infecciones de
superbacterias que por accidentes de
tráfico
y si el problema se escala de la manera
en que lo está haciendo la organización
mundial de la salud pero dice que en el
año 2050 la infección por súper
bacterias será la primera causa de
mortalidad en el mundo por encima de
otras muchas como el cáncer o las
enfermedades cardiovasculares pero donde
se encuentran estas superbacterias que
son tan peligrosas que nunca he oído
hablar de ellas
os preguntaréis
los nichos que más nos preocupan son
aquellos en los que el ser humano
vulnerable como por ejemplo los
hospitales
los hospitales se utilizan muchos
antibióticos obviamente y las personas
que están allí ingresadas tienen las
defensas bajas obviamente porque están
enfermos y eso a la vez los hace
susceptibles de ser infectados por
bacterias resistentes
las infecciones de los hospitales están
causando que procesos quirúrgicos
relativamente sencillos ahora resulten
muy complejos y quincy de llevar a cabo
porque existe un riesgo muy serio de
contraer una infección que complique la
recuperación del paciente desemboca en
una infección crónica o incluso llegue a
causar la muerte dejadme que os presente
hoy a largo término vista de la historia
de esta bacteria que os enseño aquí es
el staphylococcus aureus resistente a
las penicilinas es una bacteria muy
típica en los hospitales causa la
mayoría de las infecciones de los
hospitales bueno y aquí en la foto no
parece
muy peligrosa de hecho aparece como un
racimo de uvas su nombre staphylococcus
viene del griego que significa
exactamente eso racimo de uvas
es una bacteria que se encuentra de
manera natural en nuestra piel en
nuestras fosas nasales todos la tenemos
y ahí en este hábitat no es patógena
incluso nos ayuda nos previene
de contraer infecciones por hongos el
problema reside cuando se rompe la
barrera de la piel a por una operación
quirúrgica o un bisturí un catéter o una
simple inyección que puede podría
internalizar estafilococos áureos en
nuestro cuerpo y generar una infección
si nos infectan el hueso generar un
accidente o una osteomelitis sí coloniza
los pulmones nos generan una neumonía sí
coloniza el cuerpo entero generará una
sepsis general
y todas esas infecciones serán muy
difíciles de tratar si la cepa que nos
ha infectado es resistente a los
antibióticos
qué se puede hacer para combatir a estas
superbacterias qué medios tenemos
existen muchísimos laboratorios en el
mundo entero que el objetivo es entender
cómo las bacterias evolucionan sus
resistencia antibióticos y cómo se puede
desarrollar una nueva estrategia de
combate para com para vencerlas
yo dirijo uno de esos laboratorios aquí
en madrid y trabajamos con el
staphylococcus aureus resistente a la
penicilina
hasta ahora sabíamos que 'staphylococcus
aureus' genera esa resistencia a los
antibióticos mediante un complejo
proteico que es como el motor de un
coche tiene varios componentes y
necesita ensamblarse todo para poder
funcionar el motor y que le proteja que
le sirva como coraza frente al martillo
que son los antibióticos el ensamblaje
del complejo proteico ensamblaje de ese
motor hemos descubierto que ocurre en
zonas muy concretas de la superficie de
la bacteria hemos descubierto que la
superficie la bacteria no es regular es
heterogénea tiene diversas zonas de
diferente composición como si fuese la
piel de una vaca con manchas blancas y
negras y el complejo proteico tiene que
localizarse en una de esas zonas
concretas en las manchas negras digamos
para poder ensamblar se correctamente y
ser funcional
a partir de ahí
utilizando la biología molecular hemos
conseguido manipular el adn de la
bacteria hemos generado un mutante que
tiene la superficie la bacteria mucho
más homogénea mucho más regular y hemos
visto que en ese mutante el complejo
proteico no se ensambla correctamente
porque no encuentra su sitio y lo que
ocasiones que una superbacteria deje de
serlo y se convierta en una bacteria
convencional que podemos eliminar con
los antibióticos comúnmente de toda la
vida
a partir de ahí la biología molecular
nos enseña el camino decide cuál es la
estrategia del combate está estrategia
de combate es generar una bacteria que
sea homogénea su superficie para el
complejo no se ensambla hemos utilizado
compuestos que añadirlos a los cultivos
y ni vimos la producción de una cierta
grasa de la superficie de la bacteria
que hace que se deforme la superficie
que se convierta más homogénea dicho de
otra manera estos compuestos al ponerlos
en presencia de la bacteria hacen que la
piel de la vaca no tenga manchas blancas
y negras sino que sea una vaca
completamente blanca en ese momento en
presencia de esos compuestos el complejo
proteico ese motor no se puede ensamblar
correctamente y pierde su funcionalidad
lo interesante es que muchos de esos
complejos son las estatinas son las
moléculas que utilizamos para bajar el
colesterol en los pacientes con
hipercolesterolemia que tiene el
colesterol alto estoy seguro que mucha
gente en este auditorio está donando
estatinas también se pueden preguntar
cuánto tiempo hace que no contra una
infección
una combinación de estatinas
con antibióticos vemos que es capaz de
matar
a cepas que son resistentes a los
antibióticos que comúnmente no tenemos
ninguna estrategia de cómo hacerlo
y otro aspecto muy importante de este
trabajo
es que podemos o tenemos la esperanza de
poder volver a reciclar antibióticos que
habían caído en desuso estaban
totalmente desahuciados porque la
resistencia a antibióticos de las
bacterias les había convertido en
inútiles podemos incrementar nuestro
arsenal porque las estatinas de estar
más los complejos de resistencia
antibióticos y una vez que están
desarmados podemos matar a las bacterias
con antibióticos convencionales hemos
desarrollado nuestros experimentos en
ratones están generando resultados
espectaculares y tenemos la esperanza
que en un futuro se puedan convertir una
terapia que le sirve al ser humano para
defenderse de las súper bacterias en los
hospitales pero esto solo es una batalla
ganada en una guerra que no tiene fin
porque como he dicho anteriormente la
vida siempre encuentra el camino y la
bacteria se adaptará porque tiene que
sobrevivir y seguro encuentra una vía
para evitar este tratamiento nosotros
tenemos que evolucionar con ella y
generar cada vez procedimientos más
complejos que nos permitan seguir
luchando contra las superbacterias todos
juntos los hospitales los médicos los
centros de investigación y nosotros
desde nuestras casas con pequeños gestos
podemos contribuir enormemente a frenar
las superbacterias con pequeños gestos
como por ejemplo usar los antibióticos
solamente si no los prescribe el médico
porque puede ser que la infección que
tengamos no sea bacteriana y en ese caso
los antibióticos no tienen ninguna
funcionalidad cuando los prescribe el
médico
debemos terminar el tratamiento aunque
nos sintamos bien el primer día tenemos
que continuar hasta el final porque
cerrar el tratamiento antes hace que el
tratamiento sea más débil y aumenta las
posibilidades desarrollar súper
bacterias cuando hayamos terminado el
tratamiento no podemos tirar los
antibióticos ni a la basura en el
inodoro porque van a parar el medio
ambiente a los ríos
y allí hay también hay bacterias que
desarrollarán super resistencia tenemos
que tener cuidado tenemos que ser
conscientes que conlleva un cierto
riesgo somete esas operaciones
quirúrgicas solamente tenemos que
someternos a ella si es necesario y por
último lavarnos bien las manos y cocinar
bien los alimentos para protegernos con
todos estos gestos y con la ayuda de los
hospitales
y los laboratorios de investigación son
las únicas herramientas que tenemos para
continuar en la carrera
con las bacterias para ganarles esta
batalla porque cada vez que las
bastillas nos han adelantado en esta
carrera
hemos estado indefensos ante ellas y
estas últimas décadas que hemos estado
adelantado que hemos estado en ventaja
han sido las de kas las más saludables
de la historia de la humanidad
debemos proteger esa ventaja debemos
gestionar bien nuestros recursos que
tanto trabajo y tanto esfuerzo nos ha
costado conseguir
[Aplausos]
[Música]